now this is what I've travelled into the
wild for the chutney of the Derulo's no
one missed it hmm I just wow
mmm spicy yeah Jesus Christ it's hot huh
yeah but it is absolutely delicious I
mean really this fresh
I'm never gonna touch mango chutney for
the rest of my life but the this is not
a fruit
how do you make that if you like convict
me in the jungle I'll show you what is
this thing okay mmm there's a secret get
into the jungle yeah a foreign it's a
good not sure actually sometimes
chocolate meter falls I'm Terry after no
matter what is it inside that chutney
that makes it so bloody delicious
it seems the mystery ingredient is at
the top of this 80-foot tree is making
step we heard of a ladder ladder no no
no no what's your one thing isn't it
yes will you listen later so that's
surprising what about a safety rope and
also to hook he's cutting down a branch
with what looks like a nest on it oh so
this is the thing on him that's it yeah
oh my gosh you'll look so the chutneys
made out of ants and they bite
everywhere so Ln jesus christ almighty
aren't they poisonous I'm not poisonous
[ __ ] when they bite they bite how does
that make a chutney
and oh and eggs and skag so using the
eggs
your accent look aunt Ward says like an
ant caviar yeah so here the there the
eggs
there look at it oh come on
tasty great mmm
the only hose test hmm it's it's sour
yeah sour sour but our did ya like dem
Arun yeah like tamarind but it said this
a little bit sweetness there as well
when you burst the eggs inside this is
why I come to India any good chef loves
fresh ingredients for such a tasty dish
the chutney is easy to make red chilli
salt and ginger are ground up with some
ants and their eggs it's rich in protein
in a place where meat is hard to come by
so use 30% eggs and 50% ants
Wow okay mmm that's what you call a
chutney hmm yeah rather than that ye
goodbye mango